>> Tucker: THE CREEPY LAWYER
CERTAINLY HAS LIVED A GLAMOROUS
LIFE IT TURNS OUT.
DURING THE FEW WAKING MOMENTS HE
HASN'T SPENT ON CABLE TELEVISION
HE HAS RACED CARS WITH A SAUDI
PRINCE, HE HAS FLOWN PRIVATE TO
VISIT FIVE-STAR HOTELS IN THE
FRENCH RIVIERA.
HE ONCE OWNED A $7 MILLION HOME
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S GOOD BEING THE CREEPY
LAWYER BUT WITH A FIRST NAME
LIKE CREEPY, THERE'S NO SURPRISE
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LF
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LS
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LY
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LE
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LI
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LN
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LP
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LR
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LT
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LB
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LY
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LS
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LM
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LL
THAT THE LAWYER FINANCED THAT LY
REFUSING TO PAY THE MONEY HE
OWED OTHER PEOPLE.
ACCORDING TO AN EXTENSIVE AND
FASCINATING REPORT UNPAID STATE
AND FEDERAL TAXES.
EARLIER THIS YEAR HIS LAW FORM
WAS ORDERED TO PAY $10 MILLION
TO A FORMER PARTNER WHOM HE
APPARENTLY STEPPED ON PROFITS
FROM THE FIRM.
THE FIRM DID NOT PAY UP SO TODAY
THE CREEPY LAWYER WAS HIT WITH A
PERSONAL JUDGMENT OF
$4.8 MILLION.
NOT EVEN THE CREEPY PORN LAWYERS
LANDLORDS ARE GETTING A CUT OF
THAT.
IN A COURT IN SANTA ANA,
CALIFORNIA CONVICTED HIS LAW
FIRM -- EVICTED RATHER THE LAW
FORM FROM ITS OFFICES FOR SIMPLY
SKIPPING FOUR MONTHS OF RENT.
NOBODY FROM THE FIRM EVEN
BOTHERED TO SHOW FOR THE